Bạn hình nâu nắm và các bạn hầy vào mạnh sơ hội
Bạn thịt và các bạn hế ngày gửi nó ở trường này
Nó sẽ kinh nền nó sẽ tăng là điểm trụ nó rất là khó
Và bởi nó là làm cho bạn một cái cạnh nhất
Bạn một cái thay nữ như thế này nó các bạn nên
Nếu như mình tập sở mình đam mềm, có chính thật gát thì
Mình khó thẻ sự dụng rất là nhiều giống như như như như như như an sách tính
Bởi vì trong bùi là một số mụ bài tế em của phải có một cái chiến lửa tiếp theo
Nếu như các trường chỉ thịt tăng nói, rất là một thông khó thịt
Bạn xếp rất là bạn không học để học được
Bạn có thể học được
Đần đây cũng là điều mà thực ra thì xin cứu trông tà của phải trường nhất đó
Tại vì trong các viện mà chúng ta